and this is our real thought on a
cinematic classic Inspector Gadget
wowzers well the nice thing is we can
talk about this movie we can also talk
about the show because the show fucking
amazing it's not like it was a huge hit
or anything like that but we all knew
about him we all kind of liked watching
ahead a definite formula to it that's
back which is every kid's show had a
formula and you just run through it but
it was a nice formula um and for those
who don't know Inspector Gadget the show
from the 80s had Get Smart what's his
name Johnny Adams I think would you
believe I'm Adam yeah Don Adams and he
did the voices Inspector Gadget who is
half-man half-robot
uh I don't know they ever really go into
the backstory he just kind of is I know
there was an inventor at some point but
you don't really know so anyway he's as
happily ever went into it because I
think I saw the pilot episode once and I
don't think they ever explained it not
only that but I think Gadget had a
mustache yeah no that's when he was
there going for khlyst Oh Eric the Pink
Panther they wanted to seduce ya um but
so yeah so he's this uh he's this cop
who has like he has a nice of course it
can't be daughter because like all these
cartoons be like all a bad parent but
for some reason the uncle constantly
putting their kid humming uncas are okay
okay yeah uh they're still doing what
gravity falls and all this stuff so it's
really funny um but yeah so we and the
daughters named penny and he has a dog
named brain and they go around to
solving mysteries they're trying to stop
this evil man called dr. claw we never
see and he gadget never does anything
hits even though it's called Inspector
Gadget he never actually achieves
anything he's always off doing something
stupid thinking skiing closer to the
case when really it's his niece who's
solving all the problems with this
phenomenal computer book pretty much the
worst you know iPad I because it makes
the iPad look like a clay tab yeah I've
she can open metal doors and everything
with like just pushing a couple of these
buttons that's incredible computer book
did she get that big I don't know
I she has an uncle who's half-man
half-robot why wouldn't she have this
thing um and she never ever did sure it
really should have been called penny gag
yeah but well but but that's and that's
part of why I really liked the show cuz
you know you're watching it with your
dolls like okay little kid show like
whatever is not especially funny or
anything and it's animated decent enough
but you know to whatever but what's
something I really respected about that
show is I really respected how humble
that character was how humble penny was
and that she never took the credit she
was just happy that justice was done and
she could get more done we know we know
why this is though how many cases has
she fucked up I'm sure there were a
couple where people done interesting
about me asshole uncle you thought it is
oh no no that um so that was the formula
of this show it was always dr. claw
who's the bad guy there's always these
colorful Iron Age and the next time
object and for a show that relied on
this formula it was a good formula it
was it it's a kid empowerment show yeah
it was all about the kid wields all the
power she's obviously a super genius and
has a computer book that maybe she
invented it herself
yeah oh she had a little watch too right
helical yeah yeah she had the the Dick
Tracy watch with like lasers and buh Wow
say that loud it starts not making any
sense yeah but you have a talking dog -
yeah you know it is just um but yeah
Suze it was a kid empowerment show is
all but the kid really secretly saving
the day and this is time never you never
know good great characters in cartoons
80s shows there are very few good kick
here - no really not not I always have
the catchphrase yeah it's definitely not
kids that were basically the V hero
yeah but not the title hero either which
is tits I'm realizing now as I'm saying
it out loud this really was a good
formula it was a show it was said it's
such a strange show because if you would
think if you went to pitch this okay
we're gonna do a kid show okay it's
about a kid that secretly solves all of
these mysteries okay but she never gets
the credit that's weird
and the show's gonna be named after her
uncle okay who's a bumbling idiot who
doesn't really solve the cases himself
that's weird but by this hand man half
robot wait we're not making the half man
half robot cool no it's the little kid
in her computer book and her dog yeah
also see little dog really sentient in
that but super-smart and so so yes so
there's this show it's not like you know
perfect or anything but for a kid show
that relied on formulas in the 80s and
summat it was pretty solid for a kids
show um so then this movie comes out
years later clearly just to try the tap
and establish a market because this is
back when people didn't realize just how
big this whole nostalgia thing was going
to be and that people are still making a
living haha at this kind of stuff so
this movie comes along and clearly it's
like okay there's this show but we gotta
do what every other movie is doing
because the chart says and focus groups
and stuff like that look at the chart to
a point where art is where it's at to a
point where it becomes unrecognizable to
the original source material to the
choices of the people to where the story
goes to how the characters army
everything it's completely
unrecognizable if you didn't put him
like in the hat and coat and you know
we're the only connection would be that
he can do some of the things gadget can
do but outside I would you ever connect
this to an Inspector Gadget cartoon no
it's like well you say it's inspired
casting to Matthew Broderick play a
bumbling anything so Anton just so I
make it clear cuz we take a lot of shots
at Matthew project we have never met the
guy he could be a total sweetheart we
don't know um but I can't stand his
acting I'm sorry I really try I try so
hard I'm pretty sure he wants us dead I
made that may explain the ninja in our
house he's been very quiet okay he's
lurking in the shadows very nicely I've
been attacked twice in the past week and
I'm pretty sure it's broader great
project was a secret ninja this whole
time it's like my you know I was trying
to parade as a good actor well
just as your one flaw alright very good
no I even the moment he just wowzers I
can't uh I can't
my the one where I'm just like what the
hell are you even doing is when like he
first gets the stuff in in him and he's
just like you know no I gotta get out of
here dick and acres are on leaves it's
like this is not a physical actor this
is now a physical comedian it's
debatable whether or not he's a comedian
he had like a bit role in trainwreck he
had like a couple seconds and even
thought wasn't gonna do right Doug never
had one lesson um yeah
user came Ferris Bueller but okay I've
everything else I don't get um but he
could be a nice guy we don't know um
Rupert Everett is an awful doctor globby
you can't blame him what nobody knew how
many the funny things when you say
Rupert Everett is an awful dr. Claude
bet it to me that just sounds like you
just said the sky is blue it's just
something that is the matter yes ending
on a now is your protector this is not
platonic
that anybody who cast him is dr. Clause
should have just said Rupert Everett is
it awful I why would you show dr. claw
that was the coolest thing about the
shows you've never got to it was always
this metal and you know and the the the
damn surprisingly intimidating yeah well
surprisingly intimidating villain I mean
for just oh and it's a ballad last voice
yeah the incredible voice um so it's one
of those things where it's like so but
so they took yeah they took the teeth
out of that mmm um there's so the
villain is not intimidating not scary we
know who is we see his face penny
doesn't nothing penny does nothing in
literally every single rule you could
violate above Inspector Gadget they
violated repeatedly uh-huh like just bad
uh and it's one of those things where
it's like you kind of get it that you
need to make changes to a movie you
can't just have it be the exact source
material you gotta make changes no
matter what whether it's hey it has to
just work as a movie or has to work for
a new audience just you had to do some
changes to working
no but this is again this is a time
where it's like the changes the cat
thought they could go so far with the
changes and so let's just try and hit
the audience with what we think is
popular and everything that they change
so much and you just couldn't recognize
and there was a time where now if you
make any changes the Internet's all over
and stuff with the exception of Jem and
the Holograms that's the last one I saw
where it's like this has nothing to do
with the source material at all and it
really suffered for it this really I
guess yeah nobody saw it
this is Spectre gadget really was I
guess be gem of the Holograms of that
you know year yeah I mean just nothing
to do with it uh so you're seeing less
and less of it not saying they're making
better movies necessarily but they're
trying more and more stick to the
subject matter because they're realizing
you can really piss off the fans now
it's not just the name you have to have
something that connects formula it was
for literally you had proven through
multiple seasons that kids would watch
this thing with this formula so what's
the first thing you do helps change the
fucking formula no fuck you
whose dumb idea was that well what's so
fascinating that the director of this I
didn't he also do like Alice he he did
like you know Beverly Hills Chihuahua
and Smurfs and stuff like that Roger
Castle I can't I can't even I can't even
buy think it's him I can't totally put I
can't blame the director cuz whoever got
chosen for this they literally were just
a goon for hire but you know okay even
as a goon for hire this is a horribly
directed film i I just every single time
they did some slapstick it's always
sound effect someone slipping and I
always every single time there's some
acid going home like that or no and it
was just so horrendous there's one cool
scene I remember where this guy's trying
to run away and his car which could talk
now is there in disguise as a bush and
it's actually so good that looks like
the guy just trips and falls over
nothing but then the camera goes up you
see the car with those guys as a bush
that was a good joke well and we're just
so not understanding for me and removing
penny from it completely just undermine
the front that's what made it cool to
kids was the kid solving the mystery and
then you just remove that from it it
she's a completely
perfunctory characters is no point you
know maybe what you could have done is
that you could have had something that
was like the plot to Inspector Gadget
some things I understand you can't do I
don't think you could do brain I have no
idea how you would do that and make it
work uh it kind of a kind unless it was
complete animated you know and kids
world stuff by a live act on how you
could do that but you could still have
the formula of gadget gets a note from
the chief you don't even have to explain
where he came from II can just be one
line of dialogue or maybe he is going to
his pass where he came from possibly
what and Penny's actually solving you
know the crime and ever even if you do
an origin story you can totally do that
you don't need the chief with the
message that blows up like then do an
origin story but you still have penny
solve the mystery you you can still have
you get getting an assignment but maybe
assignment ties into finding out about
us or you you don't show dr. claw and
even if you want to make him they here
if you want to make gadget the hero you
can still have penny doing most of the
work and maybe gadget is kind of
stumbling onto it or made penny showing
him the way but then maybe she gets
caught because that they haven't a lot
in the show anyway and brain usually has
to go and save her but maybe gadget is
the one that actually goes in saver and
maybe he doesn't even know that it's his
niece a saving but he still does
something that's a value I mean there's
so many other ways you could tie these
ways you could have done it yeah I loved
that show as a kid that was one of those
moments where I'm like wow like I would
no way would I have ever even have seen
it have we not know I only saw the
trailer we saw the trailer god I
literally like turned and faced the
direction of Hollywood and just went it
was very clear yeah yeah I loved that
show as a kid and I'm like no I'm not
gonna watch Hollywood take a shit over
something I really enjoyed as a kid so
and then we had to review it anyway yeah
sure and it was just as bad as you'd
imagine now the funny thing is people
keep asking like what about the sequel
if you see the sequel single so terrible
it says oh that's I haven't seen this
but I'm just gonna say this
no the sequel is not good idea in no
universe is it is it good it's still not
a great Inspector Gadget story it it is
much French Stewart
and the style of calming airing it is
much closer in spirit to Inspector
Gadget than the first movie is though
I'm not saying it's good but I actually
think this equals better I actually was
watching the sequel because it was on TV
one day and I'm like oh my god okay well
yeah I already sat through the first one
let's see a few minutes of this I'm like
you know this isn't good
same that five year olds but I'm like
this is way closer in spirit to
Inspector Gadget and French Stewart is
actually trying to fucking act like
Inspector Gadget which is something that
Matthew Broderick didn't do so like
seriously there did nothing about
Matthew Broderick is he's not even
trying he's just showed up put the hat
on
Wow this are you kidding me he said that
right wowsers miles is I got a good
gonna get out of here you did so so that
first launch is actually better not good
but better I honestly think the sequel
is better I'm not gonna say it's a good
movie but it on the totem pole of suck
between those two movies the sequel felt
much more like an Inspector Gadget story
French Stewart was actually trying to
sound like Inspector Gadget and the
movies not great but I'm like you know
what step up a bit then hey you're
starting from such a low low though so
yeah it's a uh it's a bad movie and if
you really want to see it might be just
slapstick like what not to do with
slapstick how not to do right yeah
once in a while there's a good effect I
remember when his leg stretched out and
he was running that was Alan kind of
shots like under the lay those were
legitimately good of things um but even
the car camouflage II I mean that was
obviously a practical effect it was
really there and said so when they had
the practical effects there a lot of
them weren't that bad they're actually
okay but aside from that yeah can you
think of anything no I can't think of a
thing so um yeah it kind of kinda goes
without saying like what are on his
thoughts were but you know I think it
was fair to kind of say you know even
though the cartoon was silly and then
for little kids and stuff like that
there were good elements to it in a good
formula that the carnism to be an
outlook chilled that that's
biggest insult the cartoon is goofy as
it was took children seriously
they made a child the main character
they took its audience seriously they
wanted to give something forest kids
that was kind of a spy thriller type
thing but still a lot of fun and the
movie did not it would not only was just
talking down the kids the kids it just
was actively throwing shit in kids faces
well you know in a penny of more thing
about I mean it was one of those things
I just thought back to watching a show
over and over in the formula I just
remember thinking like you know I when I
was a kid I would say she should get a
den she should get attention but it felt
like that's cool she's not looking for
it she just wants to see it justice is
done I really admire that as a little
kid like I really my money I'm not even
sure it's entirely out of humility it's
just she's that that's like her secret
identity she then puts a target on her
face if you know she comes out and it's
found out to be the one who solved all
be all but she says she wants to see her
uncle get the credit she knows they're
not gonna hire her on a force or
anything like that to is you can tell
there's always like this nice little
smile she here's the latest cool she
wouldn't be able to solve anything if
her uncle wasn't bumbling around
he's the distraction so she like he's
like smokescreen
she sneaks in like the little kid ninja
that she is because he's bumbling around
so if she ever asked for the credit and
got it the jig is up yeah Bhoomi will do
any of this shit again so I you know but
that was thing she's like she's like a
little mini superhero and the movie just
was like fuck you yeah where you get
nothing kids you won't eat art Hollywood
shit and enjoy it you know what I really
like to see I like to see a sequel to
this is vector gadget movie that is all
from Penny's point of view and where
looks like she's doing nothing it shows
like all this stuff she's actually doing
the whole time by the way enemy saw me
and then you can have like the Robo
watch in the Robo book and I don't like
that and me she has a robotic dog that
actually serves his brain or something
like two frames like an acronym yeah so
um biologic robotic animal I got Yelich
last night because I know people gasp
it's in the comments
I saw theirs if I'm right I think
there's a new show on Netflix a new
Inspector Gadget Show I have not seen it
have you no okay so don't ask us about
that we haven't seen it we all know
anything about it but I said Co is
bigger but in CGI I'm just yeah I am
like I don't know unless I hear like a
lot of good stuff about it I mean I'm
like it's as people say no it's amazing
watch it but I get the feeling that your
little kids and so is the original and
that's fine I like - Inspector Gadget is
again I don't really watch inspector yes
I'm not nowadays everyone value for kids
oh I wonder what's gonna happen Oh penny
save the day I didn't see that coming
oh don't help this gadget bumble around
like an idiot
Oh cause those I'll get you next time
gadget didn't see it yeah like it but
for a kid it's fine it's good message -
mortals it's like it's like scooby-doo I
don't watch classic episodes of
scooby-doo that much nowadays it's all
the same yeah but that's the fun of it
as a kid now watch I'll get all these
people just like hunter you know what
skill be doing the hiset development of
the gadget character has really come a
long way it's the new avatar the last
airbender it's like you should see the
new scooby-doo movies I'm like
eventually I'm nodded way me scooby-doo
- or no there's a whole bunch of
animated films that I guess apparently
they're supporting like where they meet
wrestlers and stuff like that yeah I
don't wanna me kiss there was one was
showing me a clip and it got all really
meta and was breaking the fourth wall
and I'm like okay this is really amusing
I'm like if they're doing this
tongue-in-cheek maybe I'll watch it so
but yeah but I don't watch classic
episodes of scooby-doo I feel like that
was meant for kids and and you know your
kitchen skills and everything yeah and I
enjoyed it but I'm a grown adult so I'm
like okay well it's always going to be
the guy who's there for about three
minutes of screen time doesn't say much
and it's never the obviously ugly guy
who seems mean and cranky you know it's
like you figure out the formula right
away yeah almost like cuz it's meant for
five minutes
yeah I think as an adult you want stuff
that's gonna challenge you a little bit
of your times more sensitive so you want
to find others and there's nothing
against scooby-doo yeah no inspector
gets five
they're both five Yanis they don't they
don't challenge me as much now that I'm
like 36 just saying probably more
concerned if you're 36 in you are
watching scooby-doo Inspector Gadget oh
you just probably pissed off probably a
little 36 year-old Hotere yo but it's
it's fine if you watching great I we
watch adult stuff gravity falls yes
exactly so um yeah that's about it this
movie sucks have a nice day fuck you
Hollywood